this episode of real law review was made
possible by skillshare
learn to think like a lawyer for free
for two months by clicking the link in
the description
paul manafort lied so much that the
mueller team is ripping up his plea
agreement
this is very unusual and this has huge
implications for the entire
trump legal defense team let's think
like a lawyer
[Music]
on today's real law review i want to
talk about all the implications that
come as a result of paul manafort
breaking the terms of his plea agreement
with the mueller legal team
including one why manafort is going to
jail for a
long time two how he has exposed all of
his communications with president trump
and the rest of the trump team
including those protected by
attorney-client privilege and three
why even a pardon won't save paul
manafort
this has huge implications for everyone
including the president
you may recall that paul manafort was
indicted in two separate jurisdictions
he was a defendant in one particular
criminal case in the eastern district of
virginia that's federal court
as well as the district of dc which
again is another federal district
the eastern district of virginia because
of its proximity to dc
handles a lot of very high profile
federal cases
and this is no exception to that the
virginia case went to trial first
paul manafort was convicted on most of
the crimes alleged in
the eastern district of virginia case
and the jury hung
on a few of those claims meaning they
weren't able to come to an
unanimous decision on those particular
claims
as a result of losing so many of the
claims in the virginia case
enough to put him away for the rest of
his life manafort and his legal team
decided to plead out in dc meaning he
took a plea agreement
where he got a reduced sentence in
exchange for him cooperating
with the ongoing mueller investigation
not surprisingly the plea agreement that
mueller and manafort entered into
requires that
manafort cooperate entirely not only
into the actual crimes that he was
indicted and
convicted of but also for any
investigations that mueller wants his
cooperation
with and that manafort might have some
information that would help out
manafort pleaded pursuant to an
agreement that required his fully
truthfully completely and forthrightly
cooperating
with the government according to the
sentencing memo that the mueller team
just filed the plea agreement provides
that if the defendant
manafort fails to fulfill completely
each and every one of his obligations
under the plea agreement or quote
engages in any criminal activity prior
to sentencing
the defendant manafort will be in breach
of the agreement
and of course a breach relieves the
government of any obligations under the
plea agreement
including its agreement to a reduction
of the sentencing guidelines
for acceptance and responsibility but
leaves intact all of the obligations of
the defendant as well
as his guilty pleas which means that if
manafort violated the plea agreement
he is not entitled to any reduction of
any of the crimes that he was convicted
of
and in fact he cannot withdraw his
guilty plea as a result
no matter what manafort is going to be
stuck with his admission of guilt
with no reduction in sentence in a
status report that the mueller team
recently filed both in dc and virginia
according to mueller after signing the
plea agreement manafort committed
federal crimes by lying to the federal
bureau of investigation
and the special counsel's office on a
variety of subject matters
which constitute breaches of the
agreement the government will file a
detailed sentencing submission to the
probation department
and the court in advance of the
sentencing that sets forth the nature of
the defendant's crimes and lies
including those after signing the plea
agreement hear it
this is a bombshell filing by the
mueller team
it is very rare for these kinds of plea
agreements to blow up
and what the mueller team has hinted at
here is that manafort not only just lied
once
and failed to communicate but lied on a
variety of different
subjects so what are the consequences of
this plea agreement blowing up
well for one the mueller team won't be
able to use paul manafort as a
cooperating witness they won't be able
to rely on his testimony
at trial they won't get him to waive his
fifth amendment rights against
self-incrimination
and of course paul manafort is going to
jail for a very very long time
the reason you enter into one of these
plea agreements is to get a reduction in
your sentence you make it easier for the
government to prove their case you admit
your guilt and in exchange the
government gives you
a letter saying that you should get a
reduction in sentence a judge has some
leeway in what sentence is actually
handed down
there are federal guidelines federal
sentencing guidelines that provide a
certain range
and the judge is allowed to choose from
within that range and the government
states that because you cooperated with
their investigation you should get a
reduction in your sentence at the low
end of the sentencing guideline range
of course when you back out of a plea
agreement like this
the government no longer needs to say
nice things about you and no longer
needs to argue that you should get a
reduction in your sentence and in fact
they will do exactly the opposite
instead the government will argue that
because of your bad conduct
you should get an enhancement in your
sentence you should be at the high end
of the range or
if you engaged in new crimes then you
can be sentenced to
additional time that was not reflected
in your original guilty plea
so paul manafort is in a world of hurt
manafort's breach of the plea agreement
and lies to federal prosecutors may be
related to a report coming out of the
uk's guardian newspaper
which reports that paul manafort met
extensively with julian assange of
wikileaks
before the 2016 election if that is
proved to be true that could have huge
implications for the conspiracy and
collusion investigation that's going on
on top of that there is yet another
bombshell that reports that while
manafort was acting
as a cooperating witness with the
mueller team both manafort
and his attorneys were passing secret
information
to president trump and the other trump
campaign defendants
this is a huge bombshell
generally speaking if you talk to your
lawyer those communications are
protected by
attorney-client privilege no surprise
there if you talk to
a third party who is not your attorney
the general rule is
there is no attorney-client privilege
whatsoever those communications are not
privileged and they are discoverable
however when you have multiple
defendants on one side
often they share what's called a common
interest which means that
what's good for one defendant is also
good for the other defendants and as a
result
it's very favorable to be able to share
information
among different defendants and their
lawyers and you wouldn't want to share
that information if it breached
attorney-client privilege and those
communications
were exposed so the court recognizes
what's called a
common interest doctrine which allows
those defendants to communicate back and
forth
to do that you have to sign what's
called a joint defense agreement which
basically just codifies that
relationship
and allows communications to go back and
forth however the wrinkle comes
when one of those defendants no longer
shares a common interest with the other
defendants
when one of those defendants enters into
a plea agreement
that defendant's interests are no longer
aligned with the other defendants the
other defendants presumably want to
fight the case and want to be proven
innocent whereas the defendant who has
pled guilty
wants a reduction in sentence and wants
to make the prosecution's case as easy
as possible
so in that circumstance those defendants
are no longer
in the same common interest so what
generally happens is that when
one defendant pleads out they remove
themselves from the joint defense
agreement so that their communications
are not
exposed and discoverable and the other
defendants communications are no longer
exposed and discoverable
but apparently that did not happen here
even after manafort entered into his
plea agreement
was a cooperating witness with the
mueller team and had pled guilty
to the crimes alleged in the district of
columbia
case he was still part of the joint
defense agreement with the rest of the
trump team
that means that the communications that
any of the trump lawyers and trump
defendants
had with manafort or his attorneys while
under the guise of this joint defense
agreement are no longer
protected if those communications and
that work product is no longer protected
by the joint defense agreement and no
longer protected by
the attorney-client privilege then they
are discoverable
if i was one of mueller's investigators
i would simply send a written request
over
to not only paul manafort's lawyers but
to all of the trump defendant lawyers
demanding that they turn over any
communications and any work product that
was shared amongst themselves
while paul manafort was a cooperating
witness because paul manafort doesn't
have the same interests as the rest of
the defendants and potential defendants
in this investigation
the common interest doctrine doesn't
apply and the joint defense agreement
can't protect
all of their communications and their
work product not only does this have
malpractice written all over it if the
clients weren't apprised of the fact
that they could be subject to these
disclosures as a result of these secret
communications
but on top of that i don't think that
paul manafort's lawyers are really going
to be able to practice in federal court
anymore
because no prosecutor would ever trust
them
to keep the terms of a plea agreement
secret and if you can't negotiate
with the government then your value as a
federal criminal defense lawyer is
really going to plummet
so why would someone do this well a lot
of people are speculating that paul
manafort is angling for a presidential
pardon and
that may be true there are two schools
of thought here
the first is that paul manafort thinks
he is the smartest guy
in the room and he can beat the federal
prosecutors it's not uncommon for
criminals to think that they are smarter
than they are and smarter than the
prosecutors who are going to put them in
jail
especially when it comes to white-collar
criminals like paul manafort who are
used to getting away with serving the
law and beating regulators
so it may be that manafort just thinks
he can get away with it he
lied his way into the situation and he
can lie his way out of this situation
we'll see the second school of thought
on this is that manafort is angling for
a presidential pardon
if he works with mueller he can get a
reduction in sentence but the theory is
that if he works with president trump
who can pardon him he can avoid jail all
together
that could be but there are some
problems with that because remember
manafort has been charged in both
virginia and dc
and there have been credible reports
that manafort is guilty of all kinds of
crimes in new york
as well and the problem for manafort is
that a lot of the same
conduct for which he has already pled
guilty
could give rise to state-level charges
specifically
in the case of virginia and new york he
could be convicted of
tax fraud and remember a presidential
pardon
can only pardon federal crimes which
would still leave manafort
on the hook for any state law crimes on
top of that the mueller team is probably
going to retry manafort on all of the
crimes for which the jury hung
in virginia and they will argue for an
enhancement of sentencing
for the crimes that manafort has already
pled guilty
in the latest status report the mueller
team has promised to lay out
all of manafort's lies and failures to
cooperate in great detail it's going to
be fascinating to read that document we
don't have those details right now
but they're going to argue for a
sentence enhancement but the bottom line
is that paul manafort is going to spend
a long time in either federal or state
prison
of course he could put that time to good
use by learning a new skill like
learning how to draw he could take
classes on how to draw comic book
characters by robert marzullo on
skillshare
in fact he could learn how to draw a
whole comic about a guy named super paul
who
resides in the mana fortress skillshare
is an online learning community that has
over 20 000 classes on
everything like design technology
business you name it
and the first 500 legal eagles to click
on the link below will get two free
months of skillshare
just by clicking the link the free
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to must-know topics
so you can improve your skills and learn
new things
just like paul manafort will when he
goes to prison
so click on the link and start learning
today and until next time
i'll see you in court